منزل وحيد مهجور ما يقرب من مئه عام يطلق
عليه المنزل الاكثر عزله في العالم يقع في
جزيره اتليداي قباله الساحل الجنوبي
لايسلندا البيت الخشبي يقع على منحدر تل
اخضر تحيط به البحار على كلا الجانبين ولا
يوجد بجواره اي متاجر او جيران او خدمه
طبعا انتشرت الشائعات والغموض حول البيت
واحده منها ان ملياردير بناه وخطط
للانتقال فيه في حال غزا الزومبي الارض
لكن الواقع ان المنزل مملوك لجمعيه لصيد
البافن الذي يتغذى على الاسماك الوفيره في
المياه هذه الجزيره المهجوره تم ادراجها
كمحميه طبيعيه يزورها ايضا السياح
لاستكشاف بيئتها ومنزلها المعزول
معقول شيد هذا البيت للاصطياد عصفور
الطيور البافلز على المهم انا عجبتني فكره
الزومبي الزومبي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات